[Music]
hey good morning party people welcome to
the honest trailer commentary for lilo
and stitch
the show will tell you all of our
uncensored thoughts about the movie uh
while we watch the trailer then we're
gonna respond to some viewer comments
show you some deleted scenes and tease
you with next week's
trailer uh i got my ohana with you uh uh
with me today
uh danielle lon mahalo
mahalo i mean aloha i don't know god i'm
butchered
thank you hello us hello and goodbye
that's close enough
well i uh excuse my mistake this was my
first time watching lilo and stitch
and i really liked it um i thought this
was a very cute kind of
i guess underrated because i don't hear
it talked in the same breath about uh
as um well it's not as good as the lion
king and aladdin but it's up there but
it's up there for me
um i thought this was a really sweet uh
a disney film in an era when i had
completely checked out of disney
i was not a treasure planet atlantis
brother bear
fan so this was like a this was fun no
wonder this got uh
three spin-offs in a tv series that i
also never saw
but uh what was your guys history with
lilo and stitch
yeah i think i was um by the time this
came out i was a little older so i
wasn't watching a lot of the disney
stuff
either um but watching it was really fun
it made me really homesick i lived in
hawaii for about seven years
um so watching it again made me really
really homesick but not for all that
elvis though
uh there is a lot of elvis on that
island elvis and don ho
uh didn't miss those but really really
enjoyed the movie a lot
uh yeah i mean this was definitely i was
not watching everything
disney in this era and i checked it out
specifically because
the the vibe on it was a little better
like and that that's kind of what
that was definitely what sort of the
culture and like thought of it at the
time and i i think i felt the same way
that like
during what was sort of a dark period
creatively for disney
this was like a promising new direction
like now
we disney's done a lot of these kind of
more comedy focused kind of
movies that are you know it's it's like
um
it's not it's not a musical fairy tale
adaptation princess movie like we're
used to
it's trying to sort of be something
different that stood out much more
20 years ago when this was made than it
does today
and yeah so this was like a bright spot
in an otherwise kind of grim few years
before pixar and you know everybody kind
of righted the ship
yeah and i mean i wouldn't call it like
dreamworksy but
it did have like some pop culture stuff
in it and it does take place
in um well i guess dreamworks doesn't do
this either but it was different for
disney it was kind of an outcast disney
movie because it takes place in the real
world
and it's like sci-fi and i don't think
disney really
touches like aliens and stuff like at
least
in my limited disney knowledge like they
don't do science fiction and outer space
stories aside from like i mean it's just
a treasure planet but um yeah it's
it's they're we usually think of them as
that storybook fantasy mode
and yeah this is something a little
different and it is i think it is a
little bit more comedy focused than a
lot of the other stuff
they've been doing in this era and
especially like disney renaissance era
when the movies always have a funny
angle but it's like
hunchback like here's the real movie and
then like let's take a comedy break with
these gargoyles and then
back to the drama yeah so super cute and
i think i liked it
probably mostly of all just from like an
aesthetic standpoint like i like the
color palette i like the animation style
i don't think that they lean too heavily
on like the
fake 3d thing that that sometimes that
they snuck into lion king and stuff like
that like this was
a lower budget disney movie and i think
that forced them to kind of be
creative and cute with the with the
tools they had which was just pen and
paper
yeah the animation on this is gorgeous
and i mean you could always say that for
a disney movie but
it's really makes you makes you long for
some hand-drawn for sure
yeah and it's it's stylized it has its
own look that feels unique to lilo and
stitch and
some disney movies do that but not all
of them there's kind of the disney house
style
that a lot of the movies are and then
every once in a while you get one that
kind of makes it
it has its own visual palette and
aesthetic and sort of design
and like the lilo and stitch characters
don't look like other disney characters
you can spot them right away
that's always interesting yeah so as far
as what sucks about this movie
um i i just say that for me it's like
it's not
so tightly plotted you could say like
lon i think you brought up like
if this was a pixar movie they'd have
huge backstories for the whole alien
federation and their origins and all
that stuff like that and
and yet it just looks like they just
mashed some animals together and
yeah to me that's the laziest part is
like first of all you're going to call
it the federation
already we're thinking star trek so
you've got to differentiate somehow and
they
they just don't it's basically just the
federation from star trek exactly
except yeah everything's like a you know
combined
it wasn't there was a disney show about
hybrid animals wasn't there
what were they uh i'll look it up
but anyway uh yeah they're just like
it's like a giraffe alien and that's the
monkey alien and it's like come on dude
do better
there was no better the wuzzles were the
disney
cartoon show where they were two two
kinds of fun wrapped up and rolled into
one you guys
oh yeah i was thinking anamorphs but um
yeah
and then yeah like the it was just kind
of uh
fakata the way they uh the way they
justified a lot of things in the in the
second to third act of like we gotta
just tie this all up in a bow and like
it's not yeah
anymore well the alien overlord
definitely pulls a dumbledore at the end
where it's just like 5 000 points to
stitch you get to stay on earth
let's just resolve this plot with a lot
of hand waves yeah and we're all best
friends now it doesn't matter who tried
to kill who yeah yeah
stop bringing up old stuff cue the
montage um
so we'll we'll go into in more detail as
we watch the honest trailer for
lilo and stitch
after huge bombs like atlantis the lost
empire and treasure planet
but before a huge bomb like brother bear
came disney animation's last hiccup of
success before bob iger said
screw this let's just buy pixar
lilo and stitch returns
the brother bear was the final straw um
and i i imagine that and pixar was just
absolutely eating disney's lunch for
that that five-year period
um so god i wonder what it was like for
bob iger to
to walk into steve jobs office and be
like can i please
well it's not like begging he's offering
him like billion
it was more like backing up several
brinks trucks
into the uh you know pixar lot but yes
but i mean what an admission of failure
i mean smart business move but like
disney
and children's animation are completely
synonymous and then to be
to just admit defeat like that and be
like we can't beat pixar at their own
game we have to
we got to bear in mind too this is only
one decade
after disney's like rise
from the ashes like jeffrey katzenberg
menkin
and you know like all of those guys
coming ashman and
turning the whole ship around with like
that run unprecedented run of success
getting best picture nominations or
whatever and so it was a real
rise and fall type situation to get here
yeah totally all right let's keep going
return to the era of flat 2d animation
that in this movie's case
is still full of curves everything has
kind of a
roundness that's puffed up a little bit
horse's legs
are bottom heavy they're chunkier at the
bottom and meat stitch
a biological weapon on a five-star gta
crime spree
he's taken a police cruiser
he's not just insanely violent
[Music]
he's not just profound pause for a
second did you guys see the uh
the um discourse online about how like
lilo and stitch like glorifies abuse
oh no no i didn't see that i won't write
i won't rehab
it's one of those where it's like what
cuz like she
loves him even though he's bad yes yeah
yeah
um she's a child uh and
as as is stitch really like that to me
stitch was coded
as like a toddler right or something
that was just created yeah well he
well he was and he's like you know an an
orphan
in some way like he has this scientist
who created him but he doesn't have you
know conventional parents
it's it's an et it's it's et again you
know it's that same that same thing
i just think stitch needs to be held
accountable and lilo for their many
crutches
but we did call the federation i guess i
would say in the honest trailer
commentaries for e.t
we did make the case that he was kind of
abusing elliot to be fair
they bond they soul bond elliot does not
say okay you can so that was like
non-consensual soul bond but that was
like sucking his life force away like
stitch doesn't go that far no exactly
yeah this movie we didn't talk about the
the et parallels are
thick in this one but maybe we'll talk
more about that it's just et plus iron
giant
is is basically this move yeah but uh in
a good way i like
this one all right keep going disgusting
no worst of all he speaks like the love
child of gollum and a minion
sneaky
[Music]
um that's one of the one of the creators
does the voice and man if we ever make
an animated feature film that's the
secret like the minions
guy the stitch guy and the uh and
the jack-in-the-box guy you do that
voice
you hold on to that and they gotta pay
you forever
people love those weird sims talking
characters yeah do the gibberish if you
ever have a chance do the gibberish
i also got a kick of uh uh um the
credits it said
based on an idea by chris sanders i
didn't know that was a credit you could
have
i have ideas i want to know was this
like a written on like a bar napkin idea
was this like a call you at three
o'clock in the morning because you had
too much coffee idea
i wanna know what kind of idea this was
yeah this was a watching
e.t and it'd be like what if
did this plus iron giant it was a bad
idea
yeah disney owes a lot of people idea by
credit if if that's a thing you can do
um all right keep going glide when
stitch meets lilo and nani
the saddest family unit in disney
history we're a broken family
aren't we lilo is friendless and poor
trying to please a fish who she thinks
controls the weather
because her parents were killed in a
storm it was rainy
and they went for a drive nani is a
constantly unemployed teenager raising
her sister
whose only friend is trying to get in
her pants ah david i owe you one
you can just date me and we'll call it
and they're both being stalked by the
world's most relentless child protective
services agent
did you ever kill anyone we're getting
off the subject
wow so he's like an
ex roswell like he's men in black right
he's a man
yeah yeah so did he so does he know
stitch is an alien from the get-go and
he's like keeping tabs on him because it
still seems like he's trying to tear
apart
this family regardless you know
multitasking is something that very few
people are capable of doing and clearly
uh bubbles has got that multitasking
gene because
he is able to both track an alien and uh
try to take away
uh the young girl from her sister and
the only family she's ever known
yeah it really seems like they're gonna
do that twist at the end i feel like
there was an earlier version of this
where cobra bubbles at the end reveals
that's why he's been there
all along and then it doesn't happen
and it's just like no i just love kids i
just love taking kids away
yeah i just gave up on being a man of
black so i could rip families apart that
my real passion
um and yeah so i feel like that might
have been a thing that was cut for time
or something that there was gonna be
some
larger payoff to him obviously being a
man in black
but they can't use the phrase because
they don't own it
um i would like to see i think danielle
you you point out like where's his
spin-off
oh yeah yeah i definitely want to see
him the
the alien tracker cia agent cps guy i
want to see
uh where else that goes oh i thought it
was just going to be a gritty very
realistic
story about the foster system oh it's
still pretty unrealistic don't get me
wrong
no aliens i think it's just him dealing
with these
troubled family the foster system but
for aliens is like
the dark reboot of men in black it's
yeah it's just called we're a broken
family
with cobra bubbles
and yeah i'm sure people are pointing
out like oh he they dive into that in
lilo and stitch four
uh lilo takes manhattan so whatever i'm
not gonna watch jason jason's also in
there
all right keep going the subject wow
that's grim
still not as good as whatever's going on
in this dog shelter what is that thing
a dog i think but it was dead this
morning then why was he in the same cage
as the living dogs you freak
thrill as our heroes are pursued by a
blatant rip-off of the federation from
star trek
captain on dick with a slightly more
lacks policy on global genocide
we have to guess the planet when stitch
escapes they'll deputize one wacky
waving inflatable arms tube man
and one guy with a russian accent so you
just know he's evil
hiding behind your little friend i mean
it's
too nitpicky to point out i think in an
honest trailer but it's like
okay this biological weapon has escaped
let's send
the guy who created it and is like a
self-admitted evil scientist
and this nerd to go down to the to fix
the problem
yeah you would think the federate like
if they are the federation from star
trek like where's kirk and spock like
you don't have a more capable
crew you could send on this mission
there's a deleted scene
i saw a deleted scene where like the
rest of the uh
crimes against nature like all the all
the hybrid animals are
um are like chewing out the head of the
federation like that's such a dumb idea
and she's like um they're right maybe i
should try something else
so i guess they just didn't want to hang
a lantern on it because uh
yeah not a good plan that feels that's
like the weakest part
like the the strong material in the
movie is all the stuff about
lilo and her family and that that stuff
the stuff about them being tracked by
these two goofballs from space is like
yeah i i really think they could have
stood to maybe rethink
how that's like they can't shoot them
because of the mosquito thing
it's all a little flimsy and it's just
like i get that you need a
something to cut to in some sort of
angle that keeps the federation involved
but
i don't know if that was the one it's
also a pretty grim implication at the
beginning that
uh stitch is only hanging around to use
them as a human shield
like that's dark well you gotta
take it you gotta have somewhere to
build from yeah but
they're building from like literally
friends a meat shield like a like a
bullet sponge for
for an alien so he he learns a lot over
the course of the story
he does yeah this experience
all right keep going it won't work
anymore to put on objectively terrible
disguises
go on a hilarious attempted murder spree
you're
mine then abandon their mission to join
the heroes at the end because because
because the movie is 90 minutes long and
pixar's riders aren't there to help out
yet
you expect me to help you just like that
fine so enjoy one of the under
appreciated gems of disney's
past that made a few much needed changes
to the formula
swapping original songs for elvis
fantasy locales for the real hawaii
and an ending that mimicked the 911
hijackings for one that didn't
that change makes sense but what's up
with the disney plus version turning the
dryer into a
pizza storage shelf back in my day
that was insane uh vanessa pointed that
out who helped helped write on this one
and i didn't watch the disney plus
version i watched whatever you know dvd
rip we have
and it was uh a washer and dryer and
then she put in her notes like why is
stitch or lilo hiding in like a pizza
box
so i cannot what an insane series of
events must have led to
uh well we can't ever hide in the dryer
because that's dangerous
we've decided that's dangerous kids
might try to do that what do they have
instead
a pizza storage shelf next to the washer
yeah
because the the stupidest thing about
this there's a long list of i thought it
was an oven
first of all the first at first question
she's hiding in an oven it looks right
which is not better
like that that's what i thought it's
like oh well it's a pizza oven wait
what but that you don't have a child
hiding a pizza oven instead of a drink
it's like it's bloody too
both terrible ideas yeah yeah punky
brewster taught us don't hide in
appliances
why couldn't you just make it look like
a cupboard or something like i know it
seems like that would have been just
as easy as a pizza storage unit
where you put your full boxes of pizza
yeah before you eat them that's some
goop stuff right there that's cloud
you know how you have five boxes of warm
pizza that you want to keep warm but you
don't want to eat it
and you don't want to put it in an oven
it needs its own it needs a little
storage unit temperature controlled
obviously right yeah
stupid this is running a pizza
restaurant out of your home kitchen
special edition effication of lilo and
stitch
yeah really here every gun in the movie
is now a walkie-talkie
the guns on this movie don't do anything
yeah they're just like little split like
yeah they shoot sports yeah
anyways all right keep going it's a
storage shelf
back in my day we played in the dryer
and we liked it oui
fight cub
molly never skipped leg day
dexter jester's laboratory bleakly fly
day
ving rings as himself hunk of burning
love
and his captain get too hot or we've
been in lockdown for way too long
galaxy pass
three days ago i must stitch at the
shelter i paid two dollars for him
see the snap i own them sorry lilo
perhaps you should read the fine print
next time this is just a thank you
letter to the animation studios for
their work on this movie
take them away boys
nice um good catch kevin on that one uh
let's see what didn't we talk about in
this one lon you you were not a music
fan
for this you you did not like the elvis
sound alike no it wasn't that it
i like the idea of instead of disney
songs or original songs in this we're
gonna just use
elvis songs i was like what a cool
concept but then they abandoned it they
blatantly abandoned their own bit
first of all they put in a really bad
original song
about how surfing is hawaii's roller
coaster which is like
they first of all they also i'm sure
have a role at least one roller coaster
in hawaii so
can confirm there are roller coasters in
hawaii so
roller coasters are hawaii's roller
coasters so that's ridiculous but
but then there's also a cover of an
elvis song instead of just putting the
elvis song in there i don't
understand well they had to do the
original because if you want to get the
original song oscar you have to have an
original song in there
and that's how we get but it's like
that's the one
yeah that's the one you think is going
to get you the oscar if it was a really
good song i'm sure i would have been
like
fine you know if it's like a new take on
you know like so yeah but
it's not very good and then i didn't
think the burning love cover is as good
as the elvis
version sure sure so that those were my
those
those are my old man lilo and stitch
music complaints
yeah and there was one other yet one
other old man complaint is that the the
titles of the book are
printed on the back of the book i
thought look funny
they just animated it weird so the time
being so we can see
that we can read about the title and it
makes it look like the books skim back
through that
and and mark that down and and rage at
the screen
that was that was offered the music
criticism
was was full of rage the the book thing
was a light-hearted
let's see what else we cut out when we
watch these deleted scenes
story jagged lilo pill
johanna my step brother is an alien
illegal alien and a maniac
was jumbo 911 obvious dr frankenstein's
the gutty professor jamba juice
close encounters of the nerd kind i'm
gonna get futuristic on his ass
lilo dallas multipass ut
aloha oi ohana and her sisters
the stitch finder's guide to the galaxy
elvis presley was a model citizen the
daily low google's elvis will not be a
fun day
these guys have watched planets explode
what could stitch have said to get that
intensive reaction
answer in the comments below
yeah i was gonna ask for that but then
you know i figured everything would get
caught by the filters and
you know they're just gonna do it in the
comments to this video now especially
nothing you're right i just moved it on
oh well just shifted it oh well flag fur
for adult content
you're welcome fandom entertainment
uh i'm sure he said something perfectly
sweet uh
let's see so um i want to tell you guys
thank you thank you so much for watching
please subscribe
please uh hit like and please comment
below with the nicest thing you can
think of saying
uh and ring that bell um i also want to
give you guys a heads up
the fandom five trivia contest is back
next week but it's a gaming one so it's
gonna be on
fandom games i believe uh uh bayley
myers our new host will be uh we'll be
hosting and it's gonna be all about
nintendo you know nintendo the mario
people
and i assume other things but if you
come by
and answer those questions you can win
real cash about
fake things like games so check that out
i assume links are in the description
below all right now we've got some
questions
uh coming in from the chat uh ryan's
picking out the best ones cody smith
writes
who are the best sisters in cinema we're
the best cinema sisters
um i think nani and lilo were was great
like it was a really good
sisterly relationship although i don't
have sisters but like that fight that
they get in at the beginning like
that's real like when they're screaming
at each other and like and then
and then they make up like you know to
put that a scene like that in a kid's
movie i thought was uh
was was really solid and and made it
real to me but i'm going to think about
the best ones while you guys answer
um i think it's got to go elsa and anna
maybe
those are some good sisters either look
it's either going to be that or it's
going to be the two sisters from coming
to america for me like those are my
uh i think you need to also point out uh
gamora
and nebula from our guardians and our
avengers films that's a very notable
sister relationship in today's movies
that's the first one i thought of
yeah i guess for me that it was just the
coven and suspiria but i don't think
that they're
actual sisters i think that they're more
like a sisterhood
yes um yeah it's right
yeah they're they're witches that are
united in a covenant but i don't think
they're like blood
but that doesn't listen sisterhood is
sisterhood
whether it's uh biological or otherwise
also uh
if we're talking supernatural horror
ginger
uh well help us out chat who are the
best sisters i'll keep an eye out yeah
two outcast sisters thank you well there
you go
check out the classic 2000 where we'll
film ginger snaps everybody
new price uh why is the voice different
than usual well it's still john
um still john bailey he is a man of many
talents and many voices
and you'll notice for pretty much every
family movie we do he does
uh the disney voice as he calls it um i
i don't know which person it's a it's a
riff on but if you watch
you know 90s and 2000s uh disney
commercials
it sounds like that it doesn't have the
epic deep-throated uh
of trailer voice so that's why it's
still john
um and what a wally impression
on mob great wally yeah no filter yeah
uh
selling that joke drew williams writes
is david the most handsome disney guy
yeah he's kind of and again
lon this didn't make it in but it's a
it's an excellent point
everybody is bumbling in this movie yeah
including david he sets himself on fire
or the
place he works on fire they definitely
fall back on the common animation thing
of like what kind of personality are we
good as well like
oh they're always clumsy you know like
that's
that's such a go-to trope and they kind
of overuse it a little in this one yeah
a lot a lot of bumbling going on
but i guess uh i think that the de facto
answer is
the man it's the it's the mulan guy
right that trains them be a man
that one he's pretty hot i think
also i mean if we're talking most most
people are going to say
that darn fox from robin hood which i i
that that's just
you know who am i to say what you find
hot
i think it's um i i think i saw like a
poll or something and it was the
the tangled guy the tangled oh
ryder thief yeah clinton rider in
writing
nobody's gonna throw gaston in the mix
sure sure or prince eric there you go
you have
you have a bevy of hunky uh princess to
choose from
um does thanos count as a disney prince
yes he does he's a disney king
um he's a disney overlord let's see
so maybe we can do this collaboratively
uh a disney fan writes
what are your five favorite disney pixar
movies in parentheses i am a big disney
fan
thank you for your question disney fan
so these are
either disney or pixar the whole
the whole i guess yeah the whole the
whole gamut wow
well i mean you know gotta throw like
pinocchio i think one of the greatest
ones of all time i would definitely
throw that one up there
um for me i really like alice in
wonderland that's always been one of my
favorites although i know it is not one
of the like universally
most celebrated yeah i'm also that way
with uh
i loved great mouse detective growing up
so much that it's really like a big
nostalgia one for me even though it's
not
most other people's favorites yeah it's
really hard for me because i was
a uh a die-hard looney tunes kid
i was i was raised on wb that was my
animation i wanted to see someone get
hit with a frying pan
um and if it didn't i wasn't into it so
i think like the stuff i was drawn to
was just like the animation in general
like i loved fantasia
growing up i thought that was like the
coolest thing i've ever seen
um and obviously more recently like
pixar's doing you know you can't
you can't underrate toy story like it's
one of the it's one of the great
animated films of all time
um pixar's also like just recently on
like a
crazy run like inside out is so good and
coco is so good
and then seoul i thought was really good
like they're just they're hitting like
existential trilogies yeah yeah like
just in the last few years which is
amazing considering how long they've
been going and how good they've been for
so long so yeah i guess it's hard to say
as not
personally a die hard disney fan like
but you got to respect it like
everything's pretty good
pretty good to great except for uh i
guess the um
the 80s and uh parts of the 2000s
yeah i mean honestly even some of that
like local like oliver and company i'm
not gonna like jump in
and celebrate but like black cauldron
was a bomb
and like there are parts of it that
irritate me like that little
dog guy i forget what his tape is but
like it also looks kind of awesome and
like there's some very cool animation in
it like
even those aren't total throwaways yeah
yeah
um okay so uh this one's
interesting miss orsat writes how's the
conair musical coming
now we do enough videos that i've
completely forgotten did we ever promise
to do a conair musical
i think i see i didn't know i don't
remember what that from either i guess
mickelei put that i don't know
please remind us because that's
something i want to do very much yeah
i don't know what that's from but like
yeah let's do it
we resold on it we've done i have a
fentanyl next is obviously we do a
musical
yeah we definitely do the conair musical
um yeah i know we've done con arizona's
trailer already but we'll do it again
just with songs
cyrus the virus is gonna have one hell
of a villain song like that
like writes itself really that'll be
fantastic um
finally rob turner uh asked an
appropriate question because we love our
food here it's pancake day what are your
pancake toppings of choice
or i guess pancake type you know if
you're like uh
if you like an alt pancake i i will tell
you
there there is a uh there's a place i
used to go
in santa monica called the bread and
porridge and they would do
these uh blueberry pancakes and i know
that's like a standard answer
but they were like next level amazing
and i miss them because i haven't been
to that place forever
uh there is also a place in downtown
lake botega louie
that do uh lemon regatta pancakes
lemon ricotta yeah and wow next level
holy crap brace yourself yeah yeah
i grew up on crepes uh just my alma's
german from germany so we grew up on
crepes uh but they were like the kind
where you would just take
a regular pancake mix and then thin it
out and then it would just be like jelly
and sugar
it's so like not fancy but it reminds me
of what being a kid
you know just like some smokers on a
crepe so i guess that that would be
mine it's like i like jelly on pancakes
it just reminds me of home
nice i mean i'm um i'm a french toast
man
if you if you uh force me to choose uh
but
as far as pancakes go yeah lemon ricotta
is amazing um
and to me they're just like they're
already a dessert so like
go just go whole hog go like chocolate
chip
bacon whipped cream like just throw
everything on there because you're only
gonna eat one
and it's gonna be like okay i'm done
with pancakes they're like nachos to me
like they have that like delicious to
disgusting thing
like so quickly very quickly right have
you ever been either of youtube the
griddle on something
oh yeah it's like a girl yeah yeah
ridiculous la place that specializes in
like
massive over-the-top chocolate chip like
with three layers
red velvet you know yeah yeah yeah
ludicrous dessert pancakes
yeah so there you go happy pancake day
to everybody i didn't even know it was
pancake day what it
was it's a uk thing yeah oh okay
i guess i should i should have checked
before putting that in i'm just assuming
that that person's right no
it listens it could be pancake day and i
just haven't heard about it i don't get
alerted for all the food days
necessarily in the uk they're known as
flop woggles i believe
um okay so uh miss sorsa al just a quick
follow-up uh ms sources reminding us
from the from the rock commentary
somebody asked which would make a better
musical
conair or the rock and i guess we kind
of started an impromptu con air
musical uh pitch so we need to
we will get on that i think we need to
revisit that and and make it real
um you know what else is real you guys
thank you for joining me and thank you
for uh
for watching this show and coming back
next week when we will be discussing a
film that's gonna go
straight to the dome that's your that's
your clue
for next week uh danielle lon thank you
for joining me audience
thank you guys love you appreciate you
see you then bye-bye
[Music]
you